gang still a few dates to hit for that
state trashy tour grab the squad and
come out and see the boys stand up
comedy then we play a little ay with the
crowd grab the squad and come hang the
big man ain't lying it's a great time
and we are coming out we got a bunch of
cities left we got Minneapolis Madison
Milwaukee two shows in Sacramento San
Francisco San Jose Washington then
obviously the we're coming home the
chickens are coming home to roost and
Philadelphia baby at the Filmore get
your tickets gang yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
if they grw to be classy yeah or they're
just a big old piece of trash trash
trash trash I'm your host a coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toies in the new edition she's
up on the roof about to do a triple
Gainer onto a folding table with a
lawnmower stra to her back in honor of
our special guest okay all right fair
enough that's a little wordy but sure m
is coming at you from right next to me
real son of a [__] this guy he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he is an international
businessman with ties to the German
underworld give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan what up gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes full video of Elo
YouTube as you know those numbers are
true to ro cooking and then obviously
the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com garbage gang check it
out it's a freaking party over there
love it have it a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what is up dude this
is an Aller for T-Bone right now this
isn't even a school girl over there this
is like make a wish now dude in a
of of the gnarliest dudes this is the
gnarliest one man you ain't lying Let's
Go Gang the long hair ain't lying cuz we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he's a very funny very successful
standup comedian podcaster stunt man and
author and you might have seen him in
but not limited to Here We Go Gang strap
in you got 23 episodes of Jackass you
got Jackass the movie Mad TV 12 episodes
of The Howard Stern Show 32 episodes of
Wild Boys Jackass number two the MTV
Movie Awards the VMAs you have Chelsea
Lately celebrity love Island WWE Raw
Crank Yankers Jimmy Kimmel Live Dancing
with the Stars The Tonight Show with Jay
Leno last call with Carson daily Jackass
3D Gotham Comedy live Larry King WTF
Conan Joe Rogan hot ones jackass forever
and my favorite Arby's Action Sports
Awards he also has multiple specials
including 2016's guilty is charged 2020s
gnarly he's also the author of not one
but two books hard kicking the nuts and
his Memoir professional idiot he has an
amazing podcast that you can hear every
week steo wild rde he has about 8
million subscribers over there on
YouTube and he has a brand new special
out right now at sto.com entitled bucket
list and let's not forget the guy's got
balls of steel give it up for the
legendary sto everybody let's go let's
go let's go yeah dude what's up dude and
by the way arb's action SP towards was a
real
thing I mean that's awesome what was it
it was
uh it was an award show and we'll be
right back man this guy's
good holy [__] yeah what Walter K I
think he just had lunch in Arby's if I'm
being honest with it it was sponsored by
Arby's okay yeah
mhm you get any hookup for that they
give you like an Arby's card or anything
when you do something like that no there
was a time when I had a a Chipotle card
[__] you had one Tony Hawk told us about
that he has one fre Chipotle yeah how
often did you use it a
lot yeah a lot I uh like I I don't have
it anymore so much it was revoked yeah I
want to say guys that uh your
representation precedes you than
i' I've had dear friends of mine call
from the show saying you got to get on
here I feel like that was from
Bert Whitney too yeah shout out to
Whitney yeah man you were like a alltime
uh wanted guest when we when this show
first started cooking a little bit who
do we want who do we want top of the
list steo you I mean yeah you were
always at the top of the list crazy I I
love that I appreciate that and uh what
a great intro man thanks for thank you
buddy um thank you so much for being
here congrat on the new special unbeliev
we got to see a little peak of it
absolutely wild yeah wild it's the best
intro I think ever yeah it's the very
steo intro it's [__] nuts I I do love
an opening
sequence yeah sure and yeah man it's a
lot of fun dude so so let's get into
this give us the uh give us the origin
story give us the childhood we know you
moved around a lot lay it on around a
lot yeah you don't have to be [__]
Freud oh we know you're trash yeah yeah
come on we're going to grade on a curve
Ste all right we're not [__] you look
sharp though I like the shirt I like the
glasses car Kelly Slater right here my
bro Kelly Slater hooking it up um okay
so born in England which I didn't know
as much as I knew about you I did not
know that so does that make you a
British citizen it makes me a British
citizen
contractually obligated to do that I
have a valid uh British passport [__] my
mom was born in Canada okay makes me
Canadian yeah got a valid Canadian
passport too my dad was born in America
nice so I'm triple National [__] what
were your parents do what how come you
were born in England what did your mom
and dad do um my dad was a corporate
executive really headed up uh
International divisions of American
multinational corporation
and when I was 6 months old my family
moved from London England to Rio de
janeo Brazil crazy because my dad became
the president of Pepsi Cola in all of
Brazil holy [__] D that's that's an all
right job right there that's a pedigree
right there right and um I spoke my
first words in Portuguese no [__]
because my parents paid such little
attention to
that I was actually raised by uh
Brazilian Brazilian Maids yeah a living
living Maids taught me to speak did your
mom work or just was your she
drank yeah shout out to it okay yeah
along with everybody else in uh her on
her side of the family um every single
leaf on the tree like utterly alcoholic
so that family tree is riddled with
alcoholism gambling drugs suicide you
name it damn damn yeah that's wild
garbage I thought it was pretty [__]
cool to be honest with you your dad
being the head of Pepsi kind of evens
that all out a little bit but I me do
big time even out you see now on my
dad's side of the family straight
Scholars academics theologians like
nobody's got less than a PhD over there
where did your dad go to school uh my
dad went to
School in Canada is that where they met
they met in Canada they did meet in
Canada okay yeah they did meet in Canada
dad he was on the path yeah but he was
also like the black sheep of the family
for going into business
really you want you want to be a money
grubbing businessman like not cool yeah
they were all Scot all like head right
but if you look at me and how I turned
out it's a little bit of like my mom's
side of the family like with this like
engine of my dad's side of the family
like I'm like I'm like deviant with on a
rocket ship sure with
purpose I want to be the most devious
guy around so uh six months old I moved
to Brazil two years old I moved to
Venezuela spoke fluent Spanish in
Nursery School man Jesus and this is him
trying to get Pepsi down down there yeah
well Dad got promoted to like uh I think
Pepsi and all of South America maybe
like that crazy yeah and
um by the age of three I I spoke three
languages fluently by the age of four or
five I forgot two of them completely I
was going to say what can you speak now
yeah but dude when I was 11 years old
they they uh said I was speaking
Portuguese in my sleep at summer camp so
it's this kid this kid's got issues
speaking in tongues and it's [__]
it's in there but I can't I have no
access to it you know just get out
throwing holy water on you right so I
moved to America when I was four and
what was was he was he that was still
Pepsi okay but when I was six so we
moved to Darian Connecticut when I was
four okay but then my dad became a big
tobacco CEO now we're talking yeah so we
moved in 1980 we moved uh I was 6 years
old moved to Miami Florida okay okay now
Miami Florida it's the 80s sure all of a
sudden the [__] news flash came in
that cigarettes were bad for you MH and
so the tobacco companies were like man
our business could be in trouble so what
the tobacco companies did was they
scrambled to buy up food companies
because like cigarettes might be taking
a beating but food's never potato chips
are going to be cooked forever baby and
there was the at the time the largest uh
corporate takeover merger in the history
of the world was when RJR Reynolds no
sorry RJ Reynolds tobacco bought nisco
or something that's right the KKR merch
man it's impressive that you knew that
I'm surprised you know that what are you
talking about I'm a fat kid and I like
heaters yeah that's the best of both
worlds for him RJ Reynolds Nabis RJ r
abisco and in that merger my dad had
what he calls an aberration Good
Year talk about bonus money coming in
yeah we moved to London England when I
was nine okay and then uh we moved and I
was there for uh like the second half of
fourth grade fifth and sixth grade then
we moved to Canada J dad was the
president of uh Nabisco Canada I think
crazy and then uh I imagine security
guards especially when you're in South
never security guards what are the
houses looking like they got be nice
houses houses got bigger as I grew up
they did yeah and uh family got smaller
my sister dipped out my dad was never
home he was always on a business trip
right my mom was super drunk okay I
cannot stress that enough yeah she was
very very drunk did you have nannies and
stuff like that all your whole life no
not my whole life so it was just when
you were in Canada it was just you and
your mom yeah and how how much older was
your sister than you she was three and a
half years older she dipped out when I
was 12 to go to boarding school okay so
she's 15 she goes to boarding school
yeah and so I'm in Canada when I was 12
then moved back to London England when I
was 13 uh finished H the second half of
8ighth grade and all four years of high
school in London England damn okay so
that was like your home base for most of
your life that's the longest Extended
State private school I very much so I
went to a school called the American
School in London England
damn with the outfits in the whole nine
yards no no outfits we didn't have any
school uniform but uh man was our school
a [__] terrorist Target I mean all
wealthy yeah like I went to school with
uh like the American ambassador to
England's son that's kidnapped city
right there sold that kid
weed jokes on him it was oregano still
for a dime bag yeah yeah I didn't put a
lot of hash in the hash
T you were selling weed that's awesome
yeah oh man uh before I graduated like a
week before graduation the counselor the
guidance counselor pulled me into his
office he says we know we know you're
selling drugs big time and if you think
that we won't expel you if you think you
can't get expelled one week before
graduation then think again because it's
happened now I was selling LS
to the
school lunch ladies everybody there was
some facts in these
accusations like there there were
perhaps some freshmen which you know
reported to their parents that they did
buy acid from me sure but they didn't
have anything yeah it was all hear
that's all [__] all hearsay corporate
lawyers are straighten that out in two
seconds yeah I I absolutely graduated
from the American School in London now
here's the [__] wild thing is that
80% of my senior class went on to ivy
league universities [__] 80% that's
crazy yeah I was a
loser for going to the University of
Miami yeah shout out to the Hurricanes
let's go kid like to have a good time
have fun at Harvard I'm getting a PhD in
nut job let's go yeah ah big time man
damn so yeah that's my uh that's my
upbring how were your grades were you a
good student they were great until I
started getting loaded you
know to say he's getting
loaded I mean it was it was like uh
growing up I always like really latched
on to something as my identity you know
it was like little league baseball and I
just felt so [__] cool when I was
wearing that baseball uniform that like
on days when I did not have a game I was
just cruising around and suited up suit
up for a game rocking it yeah that my
Canadian citizenship card is a photo of
me literally wearing over your should no
like football uniform full
bats shoulder bads under my game day
Jersey let him know you're not [__]
around yeah I felt the I felt the need
to I just you know like that hey guys
I'm Steve I can play both sides of the
ball where do you want me yeah I I would
latch on to that as my identity then
like little league sports like kind of
fell by the Wayside for heavy metal I
just I I latched on I was a heavy
metaler then it became skateboarding and
it was skateboarding was like my whole
thing and then it became being a a pot a
pot Stoner Goa yeah pot Stoner an acid
taker a daily Drinker and it was it was
that move from skateboarding to that
that really sent the the the grades into
a into a spiral did you do good did you
finish Miami oh God no
God no and were you were you aware of
the wealth as a kid did you did you know
or like was it I knew that it seemed
normal I knew that my family was not
religious because my parents worshiped
money yeah they they uh that was that
was kind of the vibe are we talking like
private jets when you were a kid and
stuff like that not like on a regular
basis or anything like that but private
jets in the 80s let's go but my dad um
crazy nuts my dad was chauffeur driven
to work in the morning really he would
leave that guy had a piece on him for
sure yeah um he he would leave for work
around the time that I would have to
leave for school but I was like just
mortally embarrassed of the idea of
being chauffeur driven to high school so
if I woke up even in England they were
all rich kids too yeah but not I would
have pulled up in a hor drawn carriage
not not everybody and like I was I was
like super just embarrassed of like the
the big house that we lived in got you
know I I I didn't want kids coming over
to see that how big was talking how many
beds I mean it was
like like maybe five stories Jesus in
London that's nuts yeah but they were
very very
narrow it was only three
atriums I mean the traffic on the
elevator
alone
yeah okay so like if I would oversleep
in the morning like uh you know in the
first couple years of high school and
and and I didn't have time to ride my
skateboard to school then I would be
stuck having to to go in in Dad's catch
a ride to school in Dad's chauffeur
chauffeur driven [__] car he probably
had a sharp suit on I bet he was D the
big newspaper wide open in the back seat
oh [__] and so I would ride shotgun and
then when I got to school I would hug
the driver and so that's my dad
yeah I know it was like that's awesome
dud K let's talk about Mt mobile
mttmobile yeah mintmobile activated Ryan
Reynolds hot guy washboard abs shout out
to him I'm juming up gang you want to be
a bozo you want to be like Ryan Reynolds
and look hot do yourself a favor get
over there to M mobile talking about
plant starting at what 15 a month pin
head 15 clams W easy peasy get to keep
your own number 5G Network we're talking
about so you can check all your naughty
sites you want no matter where you
AI uh it's uh luckily there's mintmobile
and they keep it simple so you can your
bill can stay low uh you use your own
phone you keep your same number all your
existing contacts it's not a full
overhaul you don't have to go turn
something in it's not this crazy
contract I've been saying it my wife's
been using it for years uh it's it's
easy peasy uh if there's no it's just
easy PE just keeps turning over there
you go bada bing bada boom you get uh
Nation on the nation's largest 5G
Network it's fantastic fantastic so to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month like the fat man said get
the plan shipped to your door get the
and you get the plan Shi to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com garbage
that's mintmobile.com garbage cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage do it g do it Kip
this is fume shout out to fume and OG in
in toies world baby that's right we know
them we love them they've been sticking
by us for a long long time in gang
getting out of bed can be difficult and
also Breaking Bad Hab abits can
sometimes be difficult as well it takes
time it takes discipline and it takes
fume fume is an Innovative device to let
you keep the idea of the Habit just
without the bad part with no electronics
no Vapor no harmful chemicals you're
treating your body right which is very
important these days try to take care of
yourself while you're giving up giving
your brain something to do to distract
you little distract you from the bad
habit gang do yourself a favor get fume
they got awesome flavors that you CH
from as well yeah they also have an
adjustable airflow dial that allows you
to get the the highspeed internet you're
looking for baby if you're looking for a
heavy bike pull or just a little nip off
the old block there you go uh they have
movable parts and magnets that let you
fidget so you aren't missing out on any
of the fun uh stopping something we uh
stopping something we is something we
all put off because it's hard but
switching to fume is easy enjoyable and
even fun fuma served over a 100,000
customers and has thousands of success
stories and there's no reason that can't
join fume in accelerating Humanity's
breakup from destructive Habits by
picking up the journey pack today head
to trif nume.com and use our code
garbage to save 10% when you get the
journey packed today that's trium
f.com use the code garbage to save an
additional 10% off your order today do
it and now back to the show back to the
show I remember too because uh when I
was in fifth grade dad uh worked for Del
Monte yeah in in L I don't know how that
worked out of the RJR abisco thing but
Dad was working was like president of
Delonte International or something like
that and so he had to go to Kenya to uh
to visit the pineapple Factory
straighten some people out probably
right like and and he timed his trip to
Kenya to visit the delman P pineapple
Factory for a spring the week of spring
break so that it could make a family
trip and we would go on Safari in Kenya
and I have this memory coming out of the
airport in Nairobi and being ushered
into this like fancy car and I'm sitting
in the car and like these partially
closed like people clawing at the window
begging for money like I'd never seen
like super gnarly property I'd never
witnessed it and I remember like
watching these people clawing at the
window begging for change and I remember
thinking like man what did I ever do to
deserve to be the guy in the car as
opposed to the guy clawing at the car
like I'm just I was like I'm a piece of
[__] I [__] get terrible grades in
school I'm always in trouble I'm a
constant nightmare like I knew I was not
a good kid and hear him sitting in this
car and I just like damn I think that
that kind of fed
into like the the I mean I don't know
self self-loathing Reb and uh and and I
just like I was
I I I I was I was ashamed to be a rich
kid sure man that is wild and I remember
a real lesson I learned at that
pineapple Factory it was [__] no one's
ever said that
sentence that's the first time that
sentence has ever I learned something on
my parents pineapple PL that day they
still charge you for them even though
your dad owns the company right like it
was super hot super super muggy like
there were flies all over everybody like
like they're doing the P you know the
the pineapple deal and and I and I I
went to my dad I was like Dad like like
how can you let people work in like
conditions like this this place is not
all the Flies and you know like
everything I was like and my dad
said well the the list of people waiting
for jobs in this pineapple Factory is
longer than the list of people who have
jobs in this pineapple Factory so if
anybody doesn't like it they can [__]
off and get replaced by somebody who
will work harder you
know that's capitalism baby shout out to
it and I remember thinking like [__] my
dad's a dick you know okay just wanted
to check so you thought about this all
right I'll be in the limo with my real
dad right I mean never mind the fact
that like P pepsic Cola RJ Reynolds
tobacco like like we're talking soda
cigarettes and cookies he's also a mass
murderer that guy's got B right so holy
[__] but then years later we were
filming
the like the first season of
Jackass maybe the second I don't know
but whatever we were being paid nothing
to to make a this show on MTV jackass
was just a little show on MTV and the
you know the the more heavy set
cameraman Rick kic the glass of course
kic goes over to Jeff T he says dude
Jeff I just worked 14 hours in a row
filming uh like a national TV show never
mind it was totally
global national TV show and I got and
I'm and I earned less than I would have
earned if I just shot a photo for a
Skateboard Magazine and traine looked at
him and said so go shoot a photo for a
skateboard Ste looked over goes are you
my dad and then and in that moment I was
like [__] so it's like it kind of
clicked that yeah like my dad's a dick
yes Jeff Train's a dick but but but
moreover that's how the world is yeah
yes you're not you're not wrong yeah and
you know you got to like figure out a
way to to not be re replaceable mhm you
got to have some kind of [__]
leverage on you saw the pineapple
Factory you were you were chilling this
great damn yeah dude so that was like
that was a very deep thought that's wild
yeah thanks man and I knew you were a
world traveler from your career but I
didn't know you see you you were all
over the world as a kid he did Safar
that's nuts yeah I I have this uh this
pass this expired passport like just
kind of you know um it's got a photo of
me like literally in diapers like just a
little baby like gear or
something like fully baby and diapers
passport photo and you flip through the
pages and it's like that [__] baby
went everywhere crazy that's awesome
dude such a unique uh unique upbringing
that's crazy such a such a unique blend
of garbage and not garbage well what was
I want to know like so high school
you're at you're at home your dad's
traveling obviously so it's just you and
your mom Y in London right your sister's
gone y what's like that day day like is
is it just that t is in the house is
your mom like are you like talking to
her
or we were super cool MH um and if she
was like once she once she picked up a
drink then like all beds were off was
she mixed in with like the other
Executives wives like did you guys you
guys had a life are assum over there she
socialized my mom was like you know I'm
not here to bag on my family no no no my
mom was uh super like sense of humor and
she was
like way smarter than my dad like my dad
was like focused like worker discipline
like driven but my mom like was way the
higher IQ gotcha really and my dad was
like super like stiff like kind of weird
like not really like good at parties and
stuff so Mom was like the social
engineer so there was all that stuff
going on you they would have she would
have to go to like dinners and benefits
there was that and and it was like Hey
you know don't [__] around we have
company coming to you know and we had
company entertaining yeah right you're
skateboarding down the stairs on a mega
t-shirt right Margaret Thatcher standing
at the bottom of the stairs and when
company comes over I mean all it is is
just like a [__] pissing match dude
it's just like oh well our kid just got
accepted into Harvard and it was just
like it was just like [__] you all like
[__] [__] all of you you know like
everybody was just in sat down in a room
pretending to like each other and
they're all just trying to one up each
other and brag and like it was I was
just like [__] this and and and I think
that whole dynamic made me kind of uh
like like when we were on um trips and
stuff like uh I would be just to just to
be a dick I like I would be I'd make my
dad like book my
like I'm not flying first class I don't
want to be with those people I'm going
to be with the cool people in the back
you fly first class now ah yeah
yeah not a [__] idiot I I do too I'm
with it I get it I do but I distinctly
hesitated when you ask that question
because [__] man like I I I want to
like build up my uh my coach muscles
sure I I started looking at like I I've
got pulled my dad out of retirement and
he's now my business manager no yeah and
he's teaching damn you got that guy
running your
book does he need some does he need
another client I take that guy any day
steo did 87 million in merch last
year they're selling it at like [__]
old foods and [__] well the the the
problem is that dad's like really like
you know peeling back the the onion like
looking at the thing and and like really
making me aware of like dollars and
cents how how [__] bad I am at
letting all the money fly out the window
you he's a Titan of Industry right and
so now I'm just like godd damn like now
I'm looking at the the flights like like
I'm like let me see coach next to first
class and I'm like now I'm looking at
those numbers and I'm like it hurts I'm
like [__] I'm going to
coach uhhuh especially just the way the
world's going man man like uh all this
all this High interest like like money
tightening like [__] that's for the
Nerds fly first class figure it out
later that's what I'm doing but I mean
people just aren't spending like the way
they are power of [__] Schultz for
selling out Madison Square Gardens in0
minutes seconds out to the king yeah
that
Jesus
yeah but it's pretty rad like the way my
dad can compartmentalize because it's
like well it's like emotionless they
look at as like it's just it's pure
black and white it's numbers these
numbers don't have emotions they're
sitting in one column to another there's
no now did you did you interview him for
the job did you ask him for like his
credentials and stuff like that
uh
no steo I'll see you at 6 a.m. and I
will need a driver by by but part of him
coming on board was to um for him to
interview everybody that works on my
team and of course they probably put
them through the [__] what do you do
again yeah I basically chill
man I tells people to like jump off [__]
and
stuff I'm the guy who says you got
it and we'll let you know yeah yeah the
job description phase was stressful for
everybody
crazy I just says here you get him as
red bulls is that right I just picture
you talking to your team like man he's a
real hard ass guy [__] bring your A
game I know and now it's like the latest
development is like Yo dude just tell me
how the call with my dad went I tap out
I can't hey man can you talk to my dad
for
me can you see if we can have people
over yeah you guys just give me the
cliff notes after the call because I
can't [__] deal with it I love that's
what you need though I need we need we
need that we do not need that we do we
do man damn me RJ Reynolds on the phone
I like this huh all right oh man okay
all right let's keep it moving dude we
can't we can't lose momentum no we're
not we're not we got to digest that for
a second this is [__] taking after
his dad move move move time's money boys
let's go questions per minute let's go I
got a coach ticket to pay
for Holy what were you go so what were
you and your mom doing for like dinner
on like a nightly basis was she cooking
that would depend if Mom was drinking or
not right what time would the drinking I
also there's alcohol in my family so I'm
not I'm not like right I mean
disparaging but was it like morning or
like nighttime stuff it it it didn't
work on the the hours of the day it
worked on like more of a monthly
calendar you know like like it would
when Mom picked up a drink that meant
all bets were off for the
next couple weeks maybe yeah making you
dinner I I would fend for myself dog
okay and going to school was optional
gotcha that's so there was not a lot of
oversight is what yeah so it was like if
I go to school you're not doing homework
you're probably not studying for test
and [__] when you were you know once you
started partying oh yeah okay and and
but but but if Mom wasn't drinking then
she would make dinner we would eat
together did you buy your lunch at
school where they have school lunch
probably a nice nice setup over there
they had they had lunch at school
okay all British food um figy puddings
and whatnot I maybe not so much in high
school in high school it was more like
spend the lunch money on cigarettes and
stuff but before that like earlier
grades couple of Chester Fields 100% I
just i' I've for went lunch and just
spent it all on Candy gotcha yeah I
pretty cand is real underrated too I got
to tell you yeah but they didn't have
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups dude you get
them from the American Embassy you to go
to the Embassy for candy this gu this
guy's got clout That's crazy dude you
have one of your Diplomat buddies
[__] it out holy [__] yeah and and
Reese's P you couldn't get Reese's P now
you can now now everything's everywhere
now they've globalized the world but
back then dude like hey your dad's
partially responsible for that yeah they
didn't have [__] Skittles
dog going to do
I do it be smoking weed without Skittles
that's how how you trying to get
sympathy for that and it's Skittles
ninstory
house uh what was your first concert
first concert that you went to Twisted
Sister [__] where at let's go Hammer
Smith odan damn and dude I just had D
Snider on my podcast [__] coolest
dude ever yeah Long Island guy love D
Snider and uh you know
when I went to tape this new bucket list
special of course I taped it in London
England right my first idea I told my
manager I was like yo my first concert
was twisted sister at Hammer Smith Odon
[__] I want to tape my special at Hammer
Smith odion and my manager was like yeah
dude what how [__] much of a flex
would it be to get Twisted Sister to
open for sure and we were all about it
but then $13 million
but then the um we had the a similar
experience that we had in in all of
Philadelphia all of Nashville was that
they were not letting this [__] show
anywhere near that building ah yeah they
like are going we don't [__] want you
they're like like a gypsy wedding
dude they're like yo triple xx rated not
for us pal we do not show Seaman exiting
the penis here
Royal Albert Hall punch a real punch a
real
stiff trying to have a good time SL did
the man yeah and that is the I
considered that skyjacking bit to be the
crown jewel of my entire career D
straight up crazy yeah D I just went
skydiving for the first time like a week
ago and I I landed and I thought in my
head I can't believe you jerked off all
two with that dude that's so gnarly yeah
I mean the the jerking off was in the
plane and I just had to time it so that
I blew a load as I exited the plane yo
shout out to the guy on your back for
just really signing off on a good time
yeah dude that guy I flew that
[__] out to England to be at the
special yeah oh yeah he's got holy [__]
all right okay let's get into some cues
here uh I got one right so you know what
was uh as you get older you start making
a couple of bucks you know via jackass
what was there any big dumb purchase
what was there any you know you got your
first big check and you're like I'm
doing this I bought uh a $20,000 gold
Rolex at one point was how much of your
net worth was that at that point [__] I
I wouldn't have had I wouldn't have no
way you still have it no I uh I lost it
during a PCP
blackout as one does yeah for all I know
I gave the [__] thing
away I think it was stolen though okay
you never know you never know yeah sure
that was that that was the night uh you
ever heard of the like the really scary
gangster rap group called mop yes yeah I
was in Fame studio recording a rap song
I had written called down with
STDs man what's up ladies it was a
hit but I don't remember recording a lot
of it and I definitely don't remember
the part where I blacked out on PCP and
[__] destroyed Fame Studio I'm sure
he probably wasn't too thrilled about
that not too thrilled that that you know
like uh people ask often like um what's
the closest you ever came to dying and
that should be on the list sure that's
up there yeah all right quick follow up
to that you know ever out on PC you know
what come I'm only putting it together
for the first time maybe the damage I
did to the
studio covered by the
Rolex man that's pretty smart
just cover it yeah we're cool take care
damn holy [__] I was going to ask if you
bite your nails or
not it's also so funny I was going
through we have a list of like hundreds
of these questions that we tailor to the
guest based on their upbringing or
whatever and dud I'm I was going to ask
you if you ever if you knew how to
operate a forklift I'm like we're
[__] way past that holy [__] do you
bite your nails um dud I'll do like one
little bite just to get it going and
then I'll pick the rest of pick it off
all right than a gentlemen you don't
get call that the can open I love that I
use it to pick my teeth after that when
I get it
going it's a homemade toothpick right
there good
call I I don't have to do that girl
because I
got
yeah yeah my grandfather used to do that
to me when I was a kid meal my but this
is for people just listening I pulled
out my uh partial denture right it's a
like a they call it a flipper it's got
teeth on it's like a retainer with teeth
on it and man my buddies guys for the
listeners out
there my buddies get really bummed out
after a meal when I pull it out and then
lick it
off it will it will catch food sure sure
you don't want to get an implant I too
much bone loss okay I got bone graphs
worst experience
of my life so that's the solution moving
forward is just that now yeah dude I'm
I'm cool with it yeah for sure I like
it's fun I'd pull it out oh yeah if
anybody should be missing has a tooth on
a retainer it's defo yeah um peanut
butter wise chunky or
smooth I'm gonna go
chunky all right that's a point in your
point in your favor yeah you're down in
the C but that is that is the classer
answer pull pull you out of it wow okay
uh so what it's it's low class to go
creamy the chunky it's not low it's not
lower class it's just
smarter the nuts is more of a you know
sophisticated palette you to appreciate
it yeah that would be more most kids
when they were kids got creamy not not
chunky yeah it was more for that's like
adult oh is that because chunky cost
more yeah be more expensive it was it I
don't yeah I don't know there was like
kids that had strawberry jam instead of
grape jelly we were a grape jelly
household I don't have strawberry jam
claws in college I don't think tell you
Nabisco like my my dad I think hails it
as one of the funniest [__] things
he's like dude we [__] had the Oreo
Factory just with [__] all over the
floor we're like let's throw it in some
ice cream sure that's what they did all
the broken cook damn was that your dad's
idea I don't know I think it was his
idea but he was like was at the meeting
give him he like cuz when that hit that
hit real hard hit real hard and it's was
just like these [__] [__] are
eating [__] the [__] off our floor
couple fingernails in there man that's a
cut thrat businessman right there I
couldn't get enough of
it um how if any how many suits do you
own um I just built um like a a a mini
half pipe in my backyard uhhuh and I
didn't want it to be like by by filling
it up before you surface it you mitigate
the Noise Okay so I tossed all the suits
in
there can you tie a tie yeah okay yeah
when I was in seventh grade in Canada I
had one of those school uniforms right
that makes sense okay ever own a bean
bag chair I did you own one now I do not
own one now okay how do you feel about
fries and
Mayo uh I don't [__] with it okay but
when the ketchup runs out I'll put
mustard all over [__] fries what wild
mustard on a fry I'll put mustard on
[__] anything once the ketchup runs
out it's [__] Panic
mod yeah start freaking out yeah but not
great Pon in case you're wondering
really yeah I don't like I never cared
for a grap Pon no kidding yeah Jesus
will you stack plates at a restaurant
when you when when you if you're done
eating will I stack plates will you
stack the plates for the
server uh yeah I'll do that okay I'm
down with that and when you go out to
eat say you go out with your boys are
you splitting the check or you get it or
they get it or whatever or or are you
paying most of the time when you go out
with the squad they're probably paying
with the team like if you're with your
team you're paying yeah I I'm let's say
you and Knoxville go out to dinner are
you are you chopping up the the line
items
there I I could
absolutely I I don't really go out to
dinner with Knoxville but I but I I
picture him being uh split split it in
half kind of okay okay split in a check
that's a wild yeah yeah anybody else no
but
that that was more of a
shot okay I didn't I wasn't sure where
you were going that okay I love him but
I just I think of him as a we're going
to split the check kind of guy okay all
right but you would pick up the check
say the four of us went after dinner
would you grab the CH I I would be most
likely to do that yeah okay all right I
wouldn't even reach for my
wallet just letting you know yeah nice
uh what do you call the remote uh remote
okay okay you go gentlemen have you ever
been to a monster truck rally wait wait
wait what does a low class person car
clicker clicker somebody once called it
the buttons I think which isn't good
yeah clicker would be the shitty would
be the Trashy version of the clicker
well you put chips on a
sandwich
uh chips on a sandwich nah no I'm not
too into that okay got a little class in
him you have a go-to karaoke
song you don't want to listen to me sing
car I have a go away from the car okay
uh how many Fast and the Furious movies
have you seen none okay what was the
first movie you saw in theaters as a
kid oh man it would have been some
[__] that my parents made me go to
like Chariots of Fire some [__] like
that that's classy yeah that's pretty
goty Award winner godamn it uh are you
currently in any beef with a neighbor
ooh it doesn't have to be big but just
something that like you know I think the
halfpipe in the backyard might piss a
couple people off I I haven't gotten any
complaints about the halfpipe okay
plenty of complaints about the three
dogs three goats and you got goats three
cat yeah I've got goats in the Hollywood
Hills what are you doing with the goats
I [__] with them
dude all right they're good shits I
don't know what to what like my girl and
I our house is an animal sanctuary
starter kit okay yeah I respect that all
right
um interesting where are you shopping
now you tightened everything up I mean
I've never not shopped at Target for all
your clothes and stuff comes from Target
really yeah what about food where you
where you guys shopping for food out in
La we just made a concerted decision to
knock it off with the nson really go to
sprouts sprouts is a little elated no
it's uh cheaper cheaper than so Gelson's
more expect you're cutting back and
going from Gelson to spr gson is for
straight
suckers hear that out there yeah not uh
what's it called luu or what's what's
the fancy aan is for super
suers it's like $20 for a [__]
pineapple and who's going to the groc
grocy store do you go to the grocery
store like if I if if I'm in the store
on a Sunday I see steo pushing the cart
you will really feeling avocados and
[__] yeah I mean my my girl a lot of the
time she'll order the [__] online she's
like it's a $25 delivery Fe worth it got
25 bucks to get it delivered but from
the place that you save way more than 25
bucks for shopping at and we don't have
to go anywhere right but I'm not I don't
operate that way like I think like oh
I'm hungry I'm in the mood for this I'm
going to go to [__] Gelson's like a
sucker you know and uh trying to kind of
curb that and maybe go other spots but
like like I will absolutely go to the
store are you guys you cooking at the
house a lot do you guys have dinner and
[__] I'm not much of a cooker okay yeah
are you guys ordering in you know what I
do the most is I drive through Taco Bell
no [__] I [__] with Taco Bell what's
your Taco Bell order dude Mexican veggie
Mexican pizza with jalapenos on
it if I'm good I'm if I'm on the good
side of my diet then it's a veggie power
bowl with jalapenos on it okay and like
uh I'll throw in some burritos like the
veggie Fiesta burrito or like the bean
and cheese I always bring my babe home
bean and cheese burritos with no onions
you're telling me you're doing that how
many so romantic I always bring my bab
bean and cheese burritos with onions
yeah that's where I bring my
sweetheart that's why I bring my little
snook them bears yeah how many times a
week would you say you're going there
when when you're home oh from Taco Bell
to Taco Bell Jesus Christ I'm going
there like three times a week e [__]
it's gnarly yeah I'm right there with
you dog let's go but but I did hear that
Taco Bell is like absolutely the
healthiest fast food
place who told one of the goats told you
that I love how he's like n what are you
talking about you're probably not wrong
especially the you're probably that
probably makes sense I think it like it
checks out that like the the ingredients
are for the most part like actual food
sure especially if you're going
vegetarian for sure yeah yeah that makes
sense and the house that you're in now
did you guys build this did you did you
did you buy it as it is bought it as it
is is it you know you seem like a guy
that you you know not a minimalist but
you're like kind of modest living is it
a normal not a lavish kind of guy right
yeah I'm not flashy okay I'm not flashy
I bought my house
you have your face on the side of your
tour Bo that's promotion and his dad
came up with that idea you son of a
[__]
yeah
touche yeah hey gam up City over here I
like it um lost my train of thought on
this okay house it's probably a little
more subtle I don't picture golden
toilet seats yeah nothing like that I
bought my house in April
2014 okay and uh yeah it's it's it's a
dope house man anything do you do
anything with like the subz fridge
Viking Range any of that kind of stuff
do anything for you do you go all out
with any of that stuff did you remodel
anything I didn't change a single
Appliance in the entire house okay you
got a pool back there added a hot tub
nice cuz I wanted to jump off the roof
okay into a hot tub and man did that
[__] hurt yeah that was not 2 and2 ft
of water
yeah dude I clipped my [__] butt on
the bench like that little like dude I
had [__] I had an alien growing out
of my [__] ass my lower back was like
[__] the movie Aliens he had a hot
tub to soak it
in uh all right so it's a standalone hot
tub like one of those it's not in the
ground correct okay who's cutting the
grass you cut the grass or you give
somebody that does that you mean the
astro turf you have astro turf yeah
that's awesome this guy parties
dude he's got a $3,000 hot tub and astro
turf it's sitting on Astro tur okay okay
and dude like you you want to [__]
find some grass to mow with the goat
it's not going to happen kind of rolling
around they roll around but we put them
up in our little Barn at night we built
a barn for them can they come in the
house no dude they are unaware that
they're [__] all day
long about it's just falling out of
their asses all day yeah dogs in the
house big time dude Big Time snuggle in
bed with you oh yeah all right what kind
of dog my lady and I brag to each other
if we have more animals on our side
of um what kind of we got the dog from
Peru that's the famous story famous
street dog from Peru Wendy okay such a
heart warming story thank you we've got
uh the rescue dog from uh the Humane
Society in Kawaii Hawaii nice that her
name is Lucy okay um good name so far
all classy names Wendy Lucy we we uh
recently lost Bernie and Olive to old
age I'm sorry hear yeah it's tough you
going to get a puppy um I'm ready to go
my my girl's got this weird thing like
I'm not quite ready yet for another not
quite over I'm like that the other two
dogs just tapped out so that we can save
more dogs there you go uh yeah way to
look at it she doesn't see it that way
sure what's the let's go into the
bedroom for a minute you got a KingSize
bed definitely have you ever heard of
Wyoming King no have you ever heard of
Alaskan king heard of Alaskan what's
bigger Wyoming or Alaskan Alaskan is
bigger no [__] yeah these these beds
Wyoming Alaskan there's even some other
ones that I can't remember the [__]
name I know California king I thought
that was no I knew of Alaska California
king is more narrow than a a standard
King but longer I like if you're a
[__] 7 and 1/2t Tall dude than you
need a California king okay but it's
more narrow it's stupid and the standard
King is I believe 76 in wide by 80 feet
long close enough to a perfect square
that it's just [__] annoying to try
and figure out which way the sheets go
gotcha whereas the Wyoming king and the
Alaskan king are are just perfect
squares doesn't matter what [__] side
of the sheets you put on the Wyoming
King is 7t by 7t what's uh what's 7 time
8486 84 yeah [__] yeah that sounds good
you the worst guy in the room it's 84 so
so you got so a tiny bit coming that
face tattoo and and you know good amount
wider but D the Alaskan king is [__]
9 ft by 9 that's what you're rocking so
that's no no we're not rocking it we're
not rocking you're in Wyoming Wyoming
like uh we're the Wyoming yet but but uh
my girl and I don't want to have kids
that's why for my bucket list special
one of the stunts was the vasectomy
Olympics and like so we took care of
that instead of having kids we want to
[__] just pour ourselves into helping
animals and that's why we're doing the
animal sanctuary starter kit got plan
all along has been buy a big ass
property and open up our own like big
animal sanctuary okay we just brought we
bought that property we have a [__]
we have a big old 44 acre ranch in
Tennessee
now the house is just like [__]
sitting there empty like and the what
I'm dying to put in that [__] house
is uh Wyoming are in Alaska yeah it's
all right oh cuz I I saw you recently
contemplating about moving to Tennessee
so that is had moving to Tennessee I
mean not necessarily moving establishing
residency there there is there is real
incentive sure in uh spending six months
and one day in Tennessee gotcha but I
don't think I'm prepared to do that I
you know I don't think that that's in
the cards at least not this next year
like I want to gradually get set up
there and and gradually kind of shift
over there right so once California has
finished [__] the bed then you'll be
able to do the full transition fact the
goats were out of here yeah we're just
right now we just want to be putting in
beds and bunkers and oh [__] here we
go and
MREs yeah they're still building a Gun
Tour go go off grid with the [__]
solar and how do you sleep do you sleep
on your side you sleep on your back Big
Time side side and then on the other
side and then my my girl calls me uh
Ferdinand fidgety fer you roll around I
got to flip back and forth do you guys
fall asleep with the TV on
um my girl can't fall asleep without the
TV I should stop calling her my girl her
name's Lux okay Lux um very
irresponsible consumer of Television
content she'll [__] she'll put it on
to fall asleep okay I do that sometimes
too though drives me nuts I'm like you
know what if it like I like to consider
my time valuable and if I'm going to
invest my time time in consuming
television content I'm going to do so
[__] deliberately and if I'm going to
like if I cap myself like I'm falling
asleep I'm GNA make M note to [__]
hit pause and save where I was at
because I'm like what am I [__] doing
here if I'm going to sleep through half
of it okay smart smart guy all right so
my my girl get falls asleep we call that
getting busted I'm like you're busted
she like oh you're already yeah She
[__] hates it like you know Jesus
she's like now I'm going to get busted
just let me get busted I'm like all
right how many pillows are you using oh
man I'm a [__] you got one between
the legs you're holding one dude I have
to have one between the legs TR I love
it I D it has to be between the legs and
if I'm with my girl then I will live
with Just Between the leg pillow and
head pillow okay but if I'm not with my
girl I am a four pillow
[__] I need a side pillow a head
pillow a leg pillow and then when I flip
over I got to have one ready for me on
the other side yeah have a side piece
waiting for you I I I fold one and and
so so I can hug it like that nice crazy
I didn't know that was trashy man I
thought that I would the more pillows
tends to the more pillows sleeping tends
to be more trashy wow sop sophisticated
based on our science you
know this ain't a no encyclopedia I me
dude when I met my girl she was like I
don't even need a pillow she didn't even
have one I was like what that's classy
that's crazy now she's [__] all up on
the leg dude don't [__] steal my leg
pillow she's rubbing you're rubbing all
on her love the leg pillow man yeah have
you had uh poison ivy in the past year
or two no okay would you say you have a
a favorite frozen
pizza what was those [__]
ones those [__] ones that uh back in
the day can you fire some off ilos
Tombstone
Douro it was like sof French bread pizza
totinos totinos toos party pizza
yeah that was the greatest moment of my
life party pizza okay okay yeah how do
you feel that thin and crispy little
[__] dude yeah it's more of like
a piece of
pizza it's like a cracker yeah not it's
it's almost like matah underneath those
things they get real crispy it's not
going to get it's not going to scratch
the itch on its own what about uh how do
you feel about pineapple on Pizza n not
me dude don't like it no I like when I
order a pizza you guys get pizza at the
house will you get P depends on where I
am if I'm on the bad side of my diet
you'll go that way if I'm on the bad
side of my diet I will [__] [__] with
dominoes okay the app might even make
its way back onto my phone so that I
just hit the button and it's already
ordered we were just talking about big
fans of dominoes over here the app
itself I mean the stuff they're doing is
is you know Dom over Pizza Hut uh yeah I
don't give a [__] about about uh Pizza
Hut but like I do like to be the one
ordering the pizza because I want to
tell the [__] person making it that I
want them to put so much [__] tomato
sauce on that thing that I have to eat
it with a goddamn spoon really yeah I'm
just likeu Drupal sauce
crazy I don't even take their word for
it because they always [__] you go
down to the Domino no no no I'd [__]
ask for a side like I want a [__]
bowl of tomatoes and you put on top of
the B of pizza sauce then I'll grab the
[__] piece of pizza and use it as a
spoon to scoop [__] massive amounts
of pizza sauce and just eat it like that
God damn yeah but I also need [__]
hella mushrooms and jalapenos all over
that thing I'll give you that okay I
like a mushroom mhm not bad what uh what
kind of car you whipping around in I
drive a Tesla y the cheap kind okay any
bumper stickers on there you can tell by
the handle like uh okay can tell by the
handle if somebody's like obnoxiously
wealthy or not gotcha uh any magnets on
the fridge at the
house magnets on my tour bus okay that's
fair yeah it's all right I'll give you
that you own an air fryer oh my girl
just bought one for Tennessee okay but I
don't know how to use
it how about a George Foreman grill
never had one never had one will you pee
in the shower oh my God I'll pee
anywhere
pal I forgot I was talking
to I apologize I I stopped getting up to
pee uh like at night yeah like okay wait
pee PE bottle in bed with your girl
straight up with my girl it started
because I got diagnosed with sleep apnea
uhhuh so I I like I got a CPAP machine
got one too yeah my my girl was like yo
it freaks me out you're like you don't
breathe and all of a sudden you're like
you know like while you're asleep she's
like I don't like it [__] you got to
get a SE tends to freak people out a
little bit when you die in the middle of
the night yeah so we got the cpat
machine and now it's like I'm [__]
having all strapped on I got the hose
[__] I'm stra and I would have to
unstrap it which would deactivate the
machine if I'm going to get up to go pee
right right I know so I got this special
pea bottle that has its own hose there's
a little hook and I grab and St I'm like
with the C PAP and I'm peeing into the
bottle and it goes through the hose and
thing but then I just got lazy I'm not
that big of a fan of wearing the PC Pap
machine we call it my pap smear and
[__] I just stopped using it but I
stuck with bottle in the bottle yeah and
I love using my pea bottle in the middle
of the night so much that I have a
travel pea bottle which goes in my
carry-on bag and I straight up [__]
dude I'm piss in a bottle laying in my
bed sometimes I I [__] spring a leak
you know it doesn't always make it all
the way in I I'll bang my pee I'll bang
my wiener against the Pea bottle back
and forth but still when I try and come
away from it I'm pissing all over myself
and the bed and I don't give a [__] I
love it okay okay fair
enough that's all class on
my travel pea bottle goddamn keny going
to say like a old gatorade bottle like a
goddamn gentleman wait so you bought
like a it's like an actual like
Contraption for what people who are like
bedridden
sure they don't want to get up in the
middle of the night or or lazy
stunt and let's some forget that he's
doing this in the middle of a petting
zoo yeah middle of a petting zoo holy I
can't I can't wait to be pissing all
over an Alaskan
game babe we need a bigger mattress for
me to pee on dude you have to be proof
that like soulmates are real that your
girl's like [__] yeah dude fire it up oh
yeah man me my girl is definitely the
one it becomes abundantly evident that I
found the exact right woman for me on
this bucket list special man
huh okay uh you got an air freshener in
that car of yours in that Tesla
do not will you eat in the car [__] yeah
you kidding me I'm at
Taco he's Drawing the Line eating in the
car yeah do you like popping other
people's pimples that I do not [__] with
okay huh you wear shoes in the house
sure yeah uh you ever have
Orangina um not in a long long time okay
when's the first time you had Nutella
you remember I think that that started
in England yeah probably early right
probably young um the uh here here's a
question that might go on your list well
hit us do you wash your hands
ow I'll be honest with you man since the
pandemic not that much not after I pee
after you pee no what are we doing your
weer is the cleanest part of your body
sitting in underwear all day yeah it's
like hey you know what this time I'm
managed to pee and not piss all over my
hands so I skipped the wash yeah yeah
yeah if you're pooping you should be
washing your hands you know
what D you know it's coming he's like he
you know what I'm at now I'll just
counter to that I'm not a handwash I
don't believe in it and I'll tell you
why it's because the [__] immune
system is a muscle you're not wrong the
immune system is a muscle that I like to
keep in shape mhm so I like to challenge
that's real dirt bag mentality I like it
yeah I like to challenge my immune
system as much as possible okay all
right uh I mean tell what do you think
about this what do you think about
this if I walk out onto the street here
in New York and I look for the nearest
puddle okay and I take this cup scoop it
up okay and I say I've got my bucket
list special coming out in one week I
can't afford to get sick and then I
knock it back
well I mean I have seen you swallow
goldfish so I mean this isn't I would
advise against it yeah well well new
promo I me what do you think
like the question is will that
perform we're talking analytics here
guys talking numbers here fat boy I
don't know what to tell
you man one of the questions was
breakfast and bed question
mark uh this is less of an aru garbage
question more of a Evo question how do
you swim in
stilts swim in stils sank pretty quickly
no yeah the uh that that's more of an
arm
thing it's more of an upper body
[Applause]
problem oh man this is an all-time cool
moment for me thank you for coming here
huh D I love it man do you enjoy
anything I don't want to say nice but
like do you enjoy like a nice dinner do
you like going out to a nice restaurant
you know every so often uh
like with with my team okay I'll say hey
you guys [__] been killing it yeah
pick whatever [__] fancy expensive
ass restaurant you want [__] book it
and [__] I'm going to go treat you
guys but it doesn't necessarily float
your you'd be happy with the Taco Bell
and peeing in the bed and the goats and
all that stuff yeah all right I do I do
like that a lot I respect but but I [__]
with seafood man I was vegan for like
you know a number of years and and I was
just it's like all right like I I'm just
going back to Seafood okay you like an
oyster you like a raw oyster not a raw
oyster but a steamed clam yeah okay you
like some Steamers yeah I [__] with some
Steamers shout out to it all right yeah
[__] with lobster [__] with
shrimp okay here's one I I always say
you ever seen a
UFO I've not but man I had that dude
Jeremy corbel yeah my podcast numbers
dude love them yeah yeah you should
[__] look at I know you guys are like
[__] probably pretty focused in on
Comedy but [__] no we're we're expanding
love to have get that [__] cor Bell
guy on dude numbers yeah yeah crazy I
mean I'm pretty I you know how to use
chopsticks sure you open your eyes
underwater in the pool sure you have a
Swiffer at the house on the bus okay
okay um will you dance at
weddings that's a that's a tough one
dude no that's a tough one
I'll jerk off out of a plane but you
will not see me doing the macarina God I
don't want to embarrass
myself have you been to a wedding in the
last like five
years five
years probably about exactly five years
AG somebody close to you um yes the
question what do you what are you what
are you dropping at a wedding as a gift
we ask everybody this we ask everybody
this like if you're going say don't they
have like a [__] registry type thing
you can do that yeah you would do
something off the registry yeah like I'm
not going to do it but
uh a
computer yeah my my girl is all about
that she'll take she'll take care of
that okay credit cards what are you
rocking you got an AMX nope no AMX yeah
I forget what the [__] problem was
with that I don't
know I don't think I qualified for an
AMX is your credit good or bad I've not
you know what at this point it's got to
be good it's got to be good credit is a
lot let me tell you what's wrong with
this goddamn
country that's
real dude if you ask somebody what their
credit scores they don't give you a
number you're jammed up credit is like
your immune
system now if I eat this American
Express
card man all right all right
I mean you're 100% trash but I love you
Jesus Christ what a [__] Legend man
so cool dude thank you gentlemen Mr
steveo the special is streaming right
now at his website sto.com bucket list
the intro is unbelievable and buddy we
can't thank you enough congratulations
everything love thank you brother I had
a blast man congrats on your success
than you brother Kippy what do you got
for them guys we're all over the road
tickets are selling out uh last few uh I
think there's like 10 10 days left for
the for the rest of the year get those
tickets uh scoop them up gang every's
going to sell out we want to see you
there app you guys are touring together
yeah so we do this is a perfect plug for
the live
shows we're both standup so we
co-headline and then we uh we fin we
close the show out playing a with the
crowd they they get their they get to
submit their areu garbage questions like
have you ever [__] your mom or
whatever you know that we co headline
T-Bone features and then we play a
little Ru garbage with the crowd so they
get a the vibe of the of the podcast why
we're all doing stand up very rude to
ask somebody if they [__] their mom
true you're not wrong there Ste he's a
man of manners I should
say ladies and gentlemen the legendary
steo make sure you check out bucket list
we love you guys and we will see you
next week peace peace